José es uno de los pocos agricultores de
pijao en el departamento del Quindío que
sigue negándose a cultivar aguacates de
hecho acusa a sus vecinos de haber
provocado inundaciones en sus cultivos
de café debido a las altas cantidades de
agua que se utilizan en los campos de
aguacates cercanos el trabajo de toda la
vida 20 años de trabajo que estoy acá
trabajando y todo me lo han acabado con
esas aguas que me echaron encima los
cultivos de aguacate también contaminan
las fuentes de agua
erosionan a los suelos y llevan a la
acaparamiento de tierras por las
multinacionales el municipio de pijao es
una zona históricamente cafetera pero
ahora cuenta con 789 hectáreas de
cultivos de aguacates El aguacate es una
mala suerte para los cafeteros de esta
región y para una tierra que además es
Sagrada es Sagrada porque esta es una
tierra fijaos una tierra de una cultura
indígena donde aventaron los pijaos por
parte los representantes de la industria
aguacatera se justifican por los números
o empleos que generan veníamos de una
crisis muy fuerte del sector caficultor
y
la industria aguacatera ha dinamizado
nuevamente la economía del departamento
que veníamos con unos índices muy altos
de desempleo y hemos aportado para que
este índice disminuya según el
Ministerio de agricultura Colombia envió
1432 toneladas de aguacates a Estados
Unidos únicamente para que estén
consumidos durante el partido del
domingo